disney has just announced that minnie
mouse is
practically speaking a frumpy lesbian
minnie mouse had been
one of the most famous cartoon
girlfriends
ever
to mickey
one of and i i'm not afraid to say it
one of the hottest mice
in recorded history and now she is
wearing a pantsuit
and is made to resemble more
say a certain former secretary of state
and presidential candidate but and
certainly not meant to look like uh
marilyn monroe
disneyland paris tweeted out this photo
of
ms mouse's
miz not miss
not mrs miz very feminist very first
pant suit which was designed by stella
mccartney they say that it looks like a
blue tuxedo i think the pantsuit looks
more like a pair of pajamas that your
mother might have purchased at t.j.maxx
okay it doesn't
which maybe is better than the pantsuit
i don't know this is all to celebrate
women's history month which is confusing
because i thought this was black history
month
i i'm not up to date on my liberal
liturgical calendar i thought women's
history month was in a month or two
whatever
the reason i bring it up
is not merely
[Music]
or really at all because i care about
the sexiness of cartoons or or candies
the reason i bring it up is because we
are living in a cult of ugliness
used to have a
of themselves that would that's bad you
don't want to do that
but now we've taken it to the complete
opposite extreme where we're developing
other disordered habits we are
attempting to make ourselves ugly
through
mutilating ourselves through
overeating through dressing poorly
through
denying
de-sexing ourselves trying to make
ourselves look androgynous or like the
other sex
we're told almost that it's that it's
wrong to be beautiful that beauty is
somehow oppressive
and this this relates to the broader
political problem
we're living in a world now where the
truth is being censored
joe rogan brings on one of the pioneers
of the mrna vaccine to give his views of
the mrna vaccine
that's dangerous you can't have that
true statements about covid about the
virus
about certain
public health measures
about the vaccines true statements that
that later turn out to be true that even
the public health authorities will later
admit are true
for a long period of time or being
censored my very show when i've said
completely accurate things
has been taken down
and then six months later the cdc admits
i was right well whoopsie too bad
we're living in a time where the truth
is being suppressed
in favor of lies we're living in a time
in which
virtue is being suppressed in favor of
vice where we're told that vice is
actually virtue and the left virtue
signals
at a time where traditional
understanding is what things that are
good to do or we're told that's bad and
things that are bad to do
obscenity wrath
profanity greed
we're told is really good
violence in some cases we're told
leftist violence actual terrorism you
target civilians to achieve a political
and we're told that's really good and
virtuous that's mostly peaceful
and we're living in a time where beauty
is being suppressed in favor of ugliness
which makes sense because the good the
true and the beautiful are the
transcendentals of being they're united
they have something to do with one
another
and so it's no surprise that when you
hate
truth and you hate goodness you're gonna
hate beauty also it's okay to be
beautiful it's okay little girls
you don't need to
you don't need to dress up like rambo
it's okay to want to be a disney
princess it's fine men it's okay to look
like a man it's not toxic
it's okay
to behave like a man it's fine
beauty is a good thing you don't when
you go look at art in a museum you don't
just need to look at the urinal in the
middle of the stall or some stupid
splotches on a canvas and try to pretend
that that's somehow beautiful when we
all know it's not it's okay to look at
the mona lisa it's okay to look at the
sistine chapel and say that's actually
beautiful that's objectively beautiful
it's more beautiful than the urinal on
the floor or the splotches on the canvas
it's not just a matter of preference
it's not just a matter of well your
truth and my truth might be different
what you think is good and what i think
is good maybe what i think is good you
think is bad and what you think is bad i
think is good so we can never know maybe
what i think is beautiful is what you
think is ugly or vice versa so it's all
subjective it's all relative right man
no actually we can know some things
because we have faculties of reason and
moral conscience and we not only need
the courage to articulate that we need
the courage to enforce that kind of
stuff or we're going to be living in a
culture full of lies full of vice and
full of ugliness
and frumpy little cartoon mice
and ugly little green m ms okay
and androgynous little bunny rabbits
in space jam and that's very very
frustrating oh hello m'lady
or my lord it is i your friend the lord
michael knowles how did i become a lord
i did not need to be knighted by queen
elizabeth i just had to be close to
established
titles your opportunity to earn the
title of lord or lady in scotland all
you need is a one square foot plot of
land and a certificate established
titles is a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards or lords and ladies
in english in your title pack you will
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land these title
packs are a fantastic gift and you could
even get a couple pack for you and your
partner where you can get adjoining
plots of land with this certificate you
could officially change your name to
lord or lady get it put on your credit
card plane tickets etc even put it on
your dating profiles they're having a
great valentine's day sale so go to
establishtitles.com
save 10 off today remember to use
discount code knowles or click the link
below that's established titles.com
knowles or just click the link below my
lords and my ladies
ring my bell ll ring
my
bell right there ring it subscribe get
notifications even though sometimes
our friends here at youtube don't send
those notifications even when you do
subscribe which is why you got to go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe
to the michael knowles show maybe leave
a five star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]